ومعنا من الرياض المحلل العقاري خالد
المبيض سيد خالد مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي
في نشره الراب حياك الله تساؤلات كثيره
حول هذا البرنامج الدعم السكني المحدث ما
الذي يمكن ان نعرفه اولا عن اليه التطبيق
وكيف يتم الاستفاده منها ايضا بسم الله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله اول شيء
اشكر لكم هذه الاستضافه الكريمه وارجو من
الله ان نقدم شيء الجميع الحقيقه هو فعلا
ما كان في الحقيقه في بدايه الاطلاق ما
كان في وضوح وكان في الحقيقه محاولات كثير
من بعض العقاريين
للحديث عن هذا
الدعم ولكن بعضهم لم يوفق
فهذا اللي خلى يمكن في نوع من الضبابيه
عند كثير من الناس لكن هو بكل بساطه
الحقيقه هو عباره عن امرين الامر الاول هو
اصبح اكثر ذكاء في عمليه استهداف الاكثر
احتياجا من ناحيه طبعا الدخل الشهري وكل
ما قل دخلك
الى تقريبا اقل من 10,000 ريال في كل ما
قل كل ما زادت قيمه الدعم بمعنى اقل من
عشره الاف كم كم
ما زادت يتم عمليه التقليل قيمه الدعم هذا
اول امر ولا اعتقد طبعا انه الامر الاول
هذا ايجابي لانه عمليه تحديد الفئه
المستهدفه بشكل اكبر
وتوجيه السيوله لها هذا يضمن استمراريه
الدعم لانه تعرف هي في النهايه ميزانيه
اذا صار الدعم يعني عشوائي للجميع بكافه
فئات الدخل سيكون هناك يعني قضيه في
الاستمرار طيب هذا هذا اول جانب الاخر
واعطى خيارات
اعطاك خيار انك انت تحصل على هذا الدعم
مقدما يصل الى 150 الف ريال الدعم اللي
المفروض تاخذه على مثلا على فتره التقسيط
لانه هو فعليا الدعم هو يدعم
الفائده عنك يعني يسدد عنك الفائده لصالح
البلد فهو غيرك بين انك انت تاخذها كمبلغ
مقدم
حوالي 150 الف يبدا من 150 الف ريال
اذا كان طبعا دخلك 3000 ريال في اقل بحيث
انك تستفيد منه في الدفعه الاولى وبالتالي
يقل عليه تكاليف الاقساط او يكون على شكل
اقساط شهريه
الى 1350 ريال شهريا
سيد خالد هل تسمعني سيد خالد
سيد خالد هل تسمعني يبدو انه انه في
ايقونه موجوده في السكايب عندك فتمنع انه
اي احد يتداخل في اثناء حديثك يعني انت ما
كنت تسمعني انا كنت اسال قبل قليل اولا عن
اللي راتبه اقل من عشره الاف ريال ما هو
الرقم الذي يستفيد منه من خلال هذا الدعم
السكني المحدد واللي راتبه كذلك ايضا اعلى
من عشره الاف ريال كيف كيف راح تتاثر هذه
العمليه وبالتالي تنعكس على سوق العقار
على الاسعار على المعروض ايضا وكذلك على
الطلب ايضا طبعا هذا سؤال جيد انا انه اول
شيء اللي راتبه 3000 في اقل حيحصل على
كامل المبلغ وهو اما يختار بين 150 الف
ريال ياخذها مباشره غير مسترده لكي تساعده
في عمليه الدفعه الاولى او يحصل على اقساط
1350 ريال شهريا مستمره معه الين يتم سداد
قيمه القرض المدعوم اللي هو الخمسمئه طبعا
كل ما زاد راتبك كل ما قل تدريجيا الى ان
يصل عشره طبعا اذا صار راتبك اكثر من عشره
الاف تحصل فقط على ميزات الدعم في الفائده
اللي هي تحمل الدوله لضريبه التصرفات
العقاريه رائعه جميع الفئ
الان على سؤالك كيف يتم الاستفاده او كيف
سيكون شكل القطاع العقاري بعد هذا التطبيق
هذا النظام انا اعتقد انه سيكون ايجابي
على هذه الفئه لانه المطورين العقاريين
سيبدا ينظرون لهذه الفئه اللي هي فئه اللي
تحتاج منزل 350 الف ريال الوحده يعني الى
500 الف ريال طبعا هذه في السابق كانت
يعني منسيه من قبل المطورين العقاريين
لانه كان الدعم موجود لجميع فئات المجتمع
وبالتالي كان لهم خيار انهم يختار اي فئه
فبالتالي اكيد المطور العقاري سيختار
الفئه الاكثر دخلا لتوفير وحدات سكنيه من
مليون ريال فما فوق اليوم سيكون هناك
يعني يعني فرص لهذه الفئه لكي يلتفت لها
المطورين الاقاليري ليبنو وحدات سكنيه
سواء كان في مدن رئيسيه في الضواحي يعني
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الرياض المحلل
العقاري خالد